tesla's stock price over the past year
is nothing less than
absurd ludicrous and downright mad
there is really no words to describe the
over
800 gain tesla's witnessed over the past
year
as people start to realize the company's
unfathomable potential
most tesla investors would agree that
tesla will become a multi-trillion
dollar company
within the next several years but within
the next 20 years
a few trillion dollars will simply be a
rounding error
for the company's monster evaluation and
if that sounds lunatic it's because it
is
but i assure you if you stick through to
the end of this video
you'll have a tough time arguing against
it and here's why
starting off it's obvious that tesla
won't get anywhere near this market
valuation
just by being a car manufacturer it's no
doubt that the real potential for the
company
is with completely autonomous cars as
well as solar
so let's start off by taking a look at
their full self-driving technology
people often disagree about when we will
have completely autonomous cars
from tesla enthusiasts claiming that
we'll see them by the end of next year
to skeptics proposing a time frame more
like 20 years
but with all the progress we have seen
so far with self-driving
and what we have witnessed over the past
few decades
when it comes to technological
advancements in general it's really not
a question of
if autonomous cars will happen but
rather when
with that being said we'll take a middle
of the road approach when it comes to
time frame and say that fully autonomous
cars
or essentially cars with no steering
wheels or pedals altogether
will be out and approved by most
governments around the world
10 years from now or in the year 2030.
elon musk is claiming that tesla will
have level 5 autonomous driving
feature complete in just a couple of
weeks assuming that he pulls through
with this
this gives tesla another 10 years to
perfect the technology
and win over government approval and
that's not a bottle cap
whatsoever as it gives tesla plenty of
time to scale up manufacturing
in order to provide an efficient
transition into autonomous vehicles
unlike the choppy transition to electric
vehicles over the past 17 years
but what's the big deal with autopilot
of course
it's an unbelievable technological feat
however
from a business perspective how much is
it really going to help
a car manufacturer another five to ten
thousand dollars in profit per car
well that would be the case if tesla
continued to sell cars
but that's not the plan elon musk
confirmed over a year ago
that tesla will stop selling cars to the
average person
as soon as full self-driving is solved
the real money makers for tesla
after developing self-driving vehicles
are robo taxis
and semi truck originally the plan for
tesla
was to develop a low volume electric
sports car
which was a roadster after that the plan
was to take the money
and knowledge gained from the roadster
to develop mid volume
luxury cars which include the model x
and model s
finally the goal was to transition into
high volume
and super high volume cars such as the
model 3 and
y and likely a compact car starting at a
20 000
price range but for several years now
there has been an additional step in the
plan which is scaling up production to
several million vehicles per year
setting up tesla to produce millions of
robo taxis and semi trucks
annually but how many people will
even use these services well the answer
is virtually everyone that is of course
unless you're watt enough to drop over
100 000
onto a self-driving car and this is due
to one simple fact
which is that driving cars will
eventually be illegal
as robots can simply drive better and
more efficiently
this honestly bums me out as though
autopilot would be a nice feature
for long road trips and work commutes i
actually enjoyed driving to the gym
around the corner or the grocery store
but unfortunately whether we like it or
not
driving will be outlawed to
significantly reduce
car related deaths and our options will
be to either use robo taxi
or buy a robo taxi but given the price
most of us will find ourselves using
robo taxis
that's not necessarily a bad thing
though as it will significantly be
cheaper than owning a car
and paying for gas and repairs and
insurance and so on and so forth
as for how many robo taxis we'll need to
meet market demand around the world
well currently there are 1.4 billion
cars around the world
and it's estimated that we spent 6
percent of our waking hours
driving thus if robo taxis were 100
efficient
we would need 84 million robo taxis but
robo taxis are not 100 efficient
they're only 50 efficient this is
because robo taxis will have to travel
empty from customer to customer as well
as when they're charging
thus this would double the demand
leading to 168 million robo taxis being
required
but that's still not quite right as not
only are robo taxi inefficient
but humans are too an equal amount of us
don't drive every single hour of the day
we'll see peaks in demand in the morning
when people are going to school and
work and in the evening as people get
out of school and work
we'll likely also see peaks during lunch
time as well as various holidays
as a result for robo taxis to be a
viable
and reliable transportation plan for the
masses
we'll need 200 to 300 million of them
and
that's with current numbers the human
population
is still rapidly growing and the demand
for vehicles is going
exponentially especially in quickly
developing countries like china
and india so we'll really need more like
300 to 500 million robot taxis by the
time robo taxis hit the mass market
especially with a lower cost of entry
clearly
tesla needs to get production up before
they can tackle this market
and that's precisely what they're doing
right now
currently tesla is building two
gigafactories
one in berlin and one in austin which
will bring the total factory count
to five and these factories are
ginormous
the new factory in austin is being built
on 2
000 acres of land and will become the
world's largest factory
once it's complete by far to put this in
perspective
the largest factory in the world as of
the start of 2019
was the boeing everett factory which
comes in at 98.3 acres
or just a 20th of course that's just the
operational area
but that really helps you understand how
big this factory will be
anyways tesla is targeting to produce
500 000 cars per factory per year
thus after these five factories are up
and running
tesla will be producing 2.5 million cars
per year
assuming they had two factories per year
as they are
this year tesla will have 20 to 25
factories by 2030.
calling at 20 factories tesla will be
producing 10 million cars per year
around the time robot taxes come out
which is what toyota
and volkswagen are each roughly
producing per year right now
and that brings us into our next concern
which is competition
sure the self-driving market is very
large
and very profitable but what about the
competition
what about toyota volkswagen and gm
tesla may have the lead but the
competition can't be that far behind
right well they are
they really are the legacy car
manufacturers have been stagnating
technologically
for a few decades at this point they're
just now starting to feel the burn of
losing market share to electric vehicles
but they're in for a world of pain when
false self-driving comes out from tesla
in march volkswagen ceo herbert declared
that tesla has a 10-year head start
in electric vehicles let's just say
his job as ceo didn't last long after
that remark
but if they're 10 years behind in the
electric race
how far behind are they on on the
autonomous race
don't take it from me or poor herbert
though just take a look at the numbers
as of april 2020 tesla had 3
billion autonomous miles that's pretty
good
but toyota and gm must be at a few
billion
or at least several hundred million
autonomous miles
oh wait second place doesn't even go to
a car manufacturer
but rather google and they're at a
20 million yeah it's not looking good
for legacy manufacturers
in all seriousness though tesla has 150
times as many autonomous miles as their
closest competitors
and they're literally going at billions
per year at this point
and it's only getting faster right now
the best move for the competitors
seems to be licensing autonomous
software from tesla and putting it into
their own cars
even if a competitor is able to enter
the market five years after tesla with
their own software
and that's a big if tesla would have
five
full years of worry-free 100 market
share
during which they can put out 60 million
robo taxis
and that's if they follow linear growth
as opposed to exponential growth
which is likely the path they'll choose
anyways
even if a competitor comes in at the
2035 mark
tesla could easily keep up their linear
growth until at least the end of the
decade
allowing for a total of 145 million robo
taxis from tesla
even if toyota gm and volkswagen come in
like
bulls in 2035 producing 10 million robo
taxis each year
that would only be 150 million robo
taxis or about the same as tesla
at that point we would have nearly 300
million robo taxis
assuming another 50 million come from
other manufacturers
like ford and mercedes we would more or
less
meet market demand by 2040 at which
point
tesla would have about 150 million robo
taxis
or about 40 market share at this point
they would simply continue manufacturing
to replace around 10
of their fleet per year at the end of
the day after accounting for repairs
charging costs and efficiency and all of
that tesla
expects each robo taxi to pull in 30 000
per year in profit
even assuming that this drops to 25 000
per year due to competition
with their 150 million taxi fleet
tesla will be profiting not tens of
billions like most
fortune 500 companies nor hundreds of
billions like top companies
but rather trillions per year at 3.75
trillion and that's just the consumer
business
next we have your trucking business
every year
truck drivers drive 140 billion miles in
just the us
of which 42 is from semi trucks or about
58.8 billion miles
however tesla can't charge nearly as
much per mile
as i do for robo taxis as these
customers are high volume customers
who would likewise expect a discount
companies like walmart and sam's club
would likely want to buy and own these
trucks for themselves
but i'm not quite sure tesla would put
them up for sale
tesla will likely use a fee per mile
structure like with the robo taxi
network
especially because these customers will
profit immensely from autonomous
capabilities
currently companies have to pay truck
drivers between 28
and 40 cents per mile calling it 30
cents per mile on average
tesla wouldn't even have to undercut the
pay to have it make sense for companies
to switch over to autonomous trucks
the thing is self-driving trucks don't
have to sleep
eat or use the bathroom adding at least
another 10 hours per day in driving time
not to mention they don't take any days
off as well
so even if tesla charged the same 30
cents per mile
companies would eat up the tesla semi as
is 30 to 50 percent more efficient than
truck drivers
at the very minimum but even if they
undercut trucker pay by a little
at 25 cents per mile they would still
profit a nice amount
as most of this is pure profit assuming
that they have a profit margin of 80
percent
and that tesla controls 40 of the semi
trucking industry
just like the robo taxi market tesla
would profit 4.7 billion per year
just from the u.s semi-trucking industry
we've still got the rest of the world
as well as the regular trucking industry
which would generate tens of billions of
dollars in profit
there is also plenty of other very
profitable uses for self-driving
technology
from replacing amazon fedex and ups
delivery drivers
to the delivery drivers working at pizza
domino's and papa john's
they could also license their
self-driving technology to behemoths in
the industry
like grubhub and ubereats but even aside
from self-driving
tesla's laden battery technology as the
former volkswagen ceo described
is quite large and tesla could license
their battery technology to various car
manufacturers
for tens of billions each but we're not
even done yet
as we still somehow have the entirety of
their energy business
currently it's estimated that even if
tesla
only captures five percent of the
re-roofing market at an
average installation price of forty
thousand they would point ten billion
dollars in revenue per year
as solar becomes a more viable option
over the next two decades
tesla will no doubt once again lead the
charge
if they're able to get 40 of the market
just like the robo taxi network
as well as the trucking market tesla
would pull revenue
upwards of 100 billion dollars per year
at the end of the day
tesla's main profit is from the car
business and more specifically
from the robo taxi network which we
estimated will bring in 3.75
trillion per year but the other income
streams aren't scoffable either
as they'll cumulatively bring in profit
in the hundreds of billions of dollars
per year
themselves so we'll call the entirety of
tesla's business to be
4 trillion in profit let's just be clear
here
that's enough money to nearly buy the
entire company of apple
twice every single year so yeah
it's a lot of money but even then
it's still not government type money
though as the us government spends more
than that
every single year even right now so
who knows where they'll be by 2040.
anyways
how much would tesla be worth if they
were profiting four trillion dollars per
year
well to estimate this we would have to
estimate their p e
ratio or the price to earnings ratio the
p
e ratio of a company is a ratio between
its yearly net income
and its market valuation for instance
apple currently has a p e ratio of 37.81
meaning that their 2.13 trillion dollar
valuation
is 37.81 times their annual net income
in tesla's case with 25 corporate tax
they would have to write a trillion
dollar check to uncle sam on a yearly
basis
which would leave them with nonetheless
three trillion in net income
now a therapy ratio would be 10
because then if you bought the company
you would make your money back
in 10 years which would mean a yearly
return on investment
of 10 percent but the thing is
companies don't just stay the same they
grow
even if tesla simply matched market
performance of
seven day person growth per year after
they would double their profit by 2050
and
that's really what investors are basing
their valuations on
so tesla would be valued at at least a
pu ratio of 20
which is still less than the current
market average of
26.17 but even at a pe ratio of 20
tesla would be worth a whopping 60
trillion dollars
if they boast a pe ratio in the mid 30s
like their tech friends including
apple microsoft and facebook
tesla would be worth an eye-watering 105
trillion dollars now will they actually
reach this number in the next 20 years
it's very well possible but not likely
as we'll almost definitely see one
roadblock or another
during tesla's growth but the beauty of
this for tesla
is that even if they simply reach a
fraction of this potential
they would already be worth tens of
trillions of dollars
and it's not just me thinking this
either many reputable investors
are in the same boat like kathy wood as
well as ron barron
in fact kathy wood who manages over 11
billion dollars
expects that if tesla is able to crack
autopilot
their pre-split stock price will be a
minimum of fifteen thousand dollars per
share
and up to twenty two thousand dollars
per share or a market cap of three to
four
trillion dollars all in less than four
years from now
thus with a large scale robo taxi fleet
there's no doubt in my mind
that they will be the first company to
reach 1 trillion
in profit in a single year and be the
first company to be valued at tens of
trillions of dollars
all within the next 20 years in 30 or 40
years however
they will likely reach hundreds of
trillions in valuation
or a stock price of over 500 000
per share without any splits but
don't get too excited here as in 30 to
40 years
we're likely to have hundreds if not
thousands of trillion dollar companies
simply due to economic growth as well as
goodwill inflation
do you guys think that elon can
autopilot tesla to 100 trillion dollars
within the next few decades
comment that down below and of course
drop a like if you guys appreciate the
depth of analysis
and consider subscribing to see more
questions largely answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one